[Music]
my name is Alex - Peck we're a temp AOL
Pastore in the colorful East Village
neighborhood of Manhattan I wanted to do
something that was very much of the
place so I wanted it to have that CD
sort of dive bar field if you're gonna
have a bar my attitude was like well you
need a bar snack I couldn't think of a
better bar snack than tacos al pastor
ALPA store
loosely translated means of the pasture
even more interpretive means of the
Shepherd or Shepherd's style so this
taco that we all love and it's basically
be municipal food of Mexico City
it comes from lamb shwarma it comes from
Lebanese immigration to Mexico and you
can start to extrapolate imagine how the
pita got replaced with the much more
present tortilla and how lamb got
replaced with a much more present pork
here's how we make our tacos here at FAO
now Pastore we start with masa which is
this fresh corn dough and we run that
through an oven we actually have an
automated oven that's solely built for
making tortillas the ingredient that's
usually missing from a perfect tortilla
is freshness the doors open at 4:00 and
that's when the oven gets fired up and
that's when we we process our tortillas
for the day so that they're always hot
and fragrant the next thing we move on
to is the pork the best cut in the
American butcher system that we can
reach for is the shoulder
it actually has that perfect mix of fat
and lean every al pesto joint has their
own proprietary marinade and we're no
different so we make an adobo which is
sort of a paste of dried red chilies and
a lot of other secret ingredients in it
and we rub that on pork shoulder steaks
those get impaled and built into this
meat sculpture of sorts and then that
rose slowly on a vertical spin there is
a theater to it you see these massive
Trump pose being licked by flame and you
see these taquitos deftly carving just
the right amount off of it the
importance of carving is that you're
getting this charred caramelized outside
and this really juicy tender inside you
shave that layer off and then you're
giving another layer a chance to set up
on the outside
people who know Alpesh store in the
United States tend to think the identity
of that taco is pork plus pineapple when
it's not what makes an al pastor taco is
that it's been spit roasted vertically
we put a nicotine Apple because that's
sweet acidic contrast to the pork to me
as a no-brainer a little bit of cilantro
and onion
and a red sauce and a green sauce you
get this sort of traffic light
chromatography on the taco that I love
those salsas the pineapple the fresh
cilantro
that's sort of what cleanses the palate
it's all in the taco right there it's
almost like a three-course meal all in
one my first real al pastor taco and my
favorite is in a tiny little kiosk
called el wa kitto in Mexico City when
you take a look at ours it'll be very
different than that that's out of
respect I think there's being inspired
by something and being motivated by
something and copying it and that's not
what we do people are very concerned
about authenticity and tradition when it
comes to this cuisine
I love the al pastor taco in that way
because it's a shining example of how
untraditional this cuisine is in many
ways and how the greatness of it
actually came from radical change and
creativity
[Music]
you
[Music]